[Applause]
what's up guys we're pongfinity as some
of you have seen we have launched our
own table tennis racket it's a ponfinity
sensei which is a five-star complete
racket today we'll be comparing it to
the cheapest one star racket we could
find let's see what the difference is
let's put the spin to the test do some
ghost serves start off with the one
dollar racket
[Applause]
you can get at least sunscreen with that
one let's try it the pumpkin is sensor
[Applause]
the ball comes back much faster when hit
with the five star racket so there's a
lot more spin in the ball
okay i'll try to receive the spinniest
possible serve that otto can do and i'll
start with the pongfinity rockets ready
emma i'm ready
[Applause]
and i actually aimed like there
[Music]
oh
it's impossible now let's try the one
star racket
[Applause]
not bad
okay okay
it almost like eliminates the spin so
that's good with this wanna start rocket
witness this challenge
it's actually quite good control for it
i mean you can't get that much spin but
it's got feeling
you can get better curve on the
five-star one but you can do it with
both let's try out the world's fastest
serve with the one star racket
[Applause]
surprisingly good
that would have been fast
hard to get the spin on it
that was okay
well you can do it with this one but i
think we can get it faster with a five
star racket let's try it
[Applause]
oh yeah
a lot better we can do faster
[Applause]
yeah it was a lot better with this one
because you need the grip to get the
speed now let's see how it compares in
gameplay
[Applause]
it's a good racket
let's try after one of our records
[Music]
yes it's impossible to hit like quality
top spins with this all right let's take
a target shot battle first one to knock
down the cuffs wins
oh
oh yeah yeah yeah this is much better
oh come back that's my favorite one
yes
well two one
well
i guess that's 20 better maybe the
target shot isn't the best measure for
control but that was fun anyway at least
a fun experience let's try a few blocks
with the one star racket
[Applause]
[Music]
now it should be a lot easier it's a
five star racket
[Applause]
it feels so much easier with this one
yeah and anything goes
let's test some chops
[Applause]
surprisingly good chops
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a lot harder hitting from ml's
five star chops
than the one star chops
because they were a lot lower and a lot
spinnier yeah i played some rallies
against mikko with the one star racket
see how it goes
[Applause]
i have to lift the block like high in
the air
he found the block
[Applause]
oh nice one yeah the biggest difference
is the block
[Music]
nice
so all in all there was a clear
difference between the two racquets
especially in the gameplay if you're
beginner or intermediate to function at
the sensor is the perfect choice for you
so go and get yours from
pongfinity.store until next time